Thank You
Old guy:*uh wtf are u doing lol *
Waddup , hey big boy, nice to meet you
Oh nooooooooooooooooo
Handshakes!
Why are they so awkward?
I fuckin hate handshakes
Why?
Why do you have to handshake?
Can't you just be like "alright see ya"
What's wrong with- *distorted*
Every time there's a handshake...
Today we're gonna look at some of the most awkward handshakes *me everyday*
Just for the pure cringe of it
and uhhh
well examine some of mine (oh boy!)
Just to see where it went wrong
Hopefully I feel less bad about myself
We all had a bad handshake
At some point in our life, ok
The problem with me is I'll never forget it
I remember every single detail
I'll wake up in the middle of the night
With cold sweat and be like
FUCK
Why did I fuck up that handshake
*horrible memories*
Lets look at some immortalised handshakes
Wait, there is no way Obama has an awkward handshake
He is such a cool guy
There it is
Awwww
Ahh
What the hell!
That wasn't even to bad
Are you serious
Painfully awkward? (Stop spelling awkward wrong who ever u are omg)
Oh you haven't even
You haven't even seen pain
ABC news you don't know
My suffering...
You don't even know my suffering
Look at that
Look at that guys dead dead look
He's like,  fuck we fucked that up didn't we
That's awkward
This is my favorite one I think
Cuz
Lets just watch, it's beautiful
They do the shake
Ohhhhhhhhh!
Wohoho
Yes
Why *laughter*
UUUUUUEHHHHHH
WHY!
How
Ugh
Listen
You gotta let go
Gotta know when to let go
Some people don't when to let go
That guy's like
Alright, well I
Guess we're going on a little journey now
why couldn't he just *laughter*
There is another one like that
we've all been in that one handshake
Where the guy or girl just hold on too long
Lets watch
oh god
Please let go
UGHHHH, he
How are they still holding hands?
NO!
I genuinley can't last longer
I can't
I can't fucking watch  this shit
It hurts
It fucking hurts
Ugh
Cause he's gonna review this car
And he's like, you know motherfucker
I'm not letting go of your hand until you give me a good review for the camera
You fucking bitch
Please
Please let go of the fucking  hand
Let go of the hand
Let go of the hand!
Alright, I think I've gathered enough courage to watch one of my awkward handshakes
This one happened litteraly like a week ago
Welcome, good job
Welcome
Good job
Thank you
Cool
Cringemas!
Jack!
Let me just
Let this just be clear
That was Jack that fucked up, ok
That was, that was
Lets just see what happened
Lets deconstruct
He went for the handshake
I
Ohhh
Went for the handshake
And then he went away
How am I suposed to
How do you go away?
If you go just commit
Commit Jack, have you heard of commitment?
I bet you have, cause
What's something bad?
Gottem
That's 100% on Jack
and that's fine
Nothing else
Can I just say
Can I just say, and to myself for that matter
If you are ever, ever
You ever find yourself
On a gaming show
What so ever, whatever fucking happens
Do not shake their hand
Do not shake any hands
No brofists
No highfives
No nothing
Cause this is what happens
Ogh
I've seen it before
And it just
I wanna die
Oghhhhh
I don't know why does this bother me so much
Nothing bothers me
Trump
Trump became president
I don't care
Handshakes
An awkward handshake
That's the fucking worst
The thing
You see that guy
He has an earpiece
He has to talk to other people
he's not gonna see your hand
Just don't shake his hand
A once handshake
Can ruin everything
Look at that guys face
That's the face you make when you die
That guy fucked it up
that guy is literally Jacksepticeye
The guy on the left
Hahaha
Wait, so he hands over the mic
What was he thinking
Hey really nice to meet you
Sure
sure buddy
I think this is probably my favorite one
I, you could say I'm a kind of a connoisseur of awkward handshake
but I, I think this one has to be my favorite
Ryan Seacrest highfives a blind guy
No you wont see anyone in California
Ryan Seacrest
Did he ever comment about that
I think that's what makes it even better
The fact that he never acknowledged it
Like, oh my god
I tried to highfive a blind guy
I think I've gathered enough courage
To watch another one of mine
You see my reaction right away
Oh no, Oh no
Why is it so hard to me
Am I that awkward?
I don't think I'm that awkward
I just can't do handshakes
Just don't handshake me
I don't want to
I don't wanna touch you, ok
No offense
Who grabs?
Why would you grab
Ethan
Whats wrong with you?
That was a highfive, that was clearly a highfive
Alright and the Conan one
Which you all keeps sending to me by the way
Please stop doing that
Who handshakes during a gaming session?
You highfive
You go like this
That doesn't mean you are going for a hand shake
Like this means a highfive
That's not my fucking problem
Well I don't ever wanna do that again
Shut up
and the guy, he fucked it up to
He fucked it up to
Look at him, he did it wrong aswell
It's not just me
I'm not the only one
Look at that , that's equally bad, ok
Can you stop , can you
Stop
What else do we got?
Oh this fucking video
So he is challenging these
Girls, paid actresses I should probably call them
To make an awkward handshake with them
and if they fail
they have to makeout with him
The ultimate punishment
I was cringing
I didn't even realise I made that face
Jesus
Hey Chris, why don't you
Why don't  you gt a suit that fits you?
Why don't you get a propperly tailored suit?
Instead of paying all these women to kiss you
Alright
I mean it doesn't seem like a bad job
They're all atractive women
Marzia, Marzia
But, come on girls
You can do better
You don't have to kiss Chris Monroe
Cause you fucked up a handshake
Couse I will
If I kissed everyone I fucked up a handshake with
I would
Probably have herpes
Six times over
20 times, a million times
You fuck up a handshake
You pay the consequences
You don't just make out with people
Alright
it kinda triggers me
Because I have this condition
And he's clearly making fun of it
And I don't think that's fair
I don't think that is very fair at all
Mr. Chris Monroe
What the fuck, you guys tweeted me this
Wait, what just happened
Is that Hitler
Ohhhhhh!!
Historically awkward handshake, what the fuck
Did Hitler, did Hitler
Did Hitler just have an awkward handshake?
Oh my god
This is the greatest thing that ever happened to me
Finally
I can relate to someone
Kidding
I'm kidding
That's a pretty
He did it pretty smooth
You know the
Man, Hitler
He didn't just do the
Sorry, ok, to far, allright
This one I thought was fake
It just seemed to dumb
To not be real
So it's this guy with no arms
And shoots
He shoots and wins gold
He actually has absolutely incredible feet
Like feet
I mean feet, not shit oh no
Look at that!
You fucking idiot
I thought that was fake
To be fair
What do you do
Do you bow?
You gotta bow
Bow
That's it
We need to bring back the bowing
Simple
Like Japan
Why is it so hard?
Can we just have one universal thing
I don't care what it is
I just want one thing so it doesn't have to be so awkward
The most awkward handshake of 2012
What happend
Oh
Oh, oh, oh
I don't know why it's funny
I think it's because
People are put in a spot where they don't know how to act.
we're so programmed
Oh, this is getting deep
We're so programmed in our society
Not just what we say or how we act or what we eat
But when we're put in a situation
where we don't know what to do
It's just hilarious
I realise
What I must do now
I must take this to the great outdoors
And I must greet some strangers
And practice
I will become
The handshake master
Alright bros
That was this video
I hope you enjoyed watching
Now I wanna be clear that if you see me
Do not interact with me
Whatsoever
You may bow
Alright here's the thing
If you ever see me
I want you to bow
Bow to you sensei pretty much
And that's pretty much all you are allowed to at this point
Ok?
That's it.
No offense
Just don't  fucking touch
I'm kidding
I'm joking
Just don't
I know, I know, I just know you guys
And I know you are gonna fuck with me just because I gave you this very personal information
Alright
But anyway
If you enjoyed this video.
I think you might enjoy this one
Ohhh
It's another one about handshakes *nooo*
How about that
Running out of Ideas pewds?